hey guys Doug Walker here so a lot of
you probably saw my unfriended review
and know it was originally an attempt to
go see it follows and how the guy that
worked at the movie theater pretty much
gave away the the plot of the movie
which was supposed to be like Shiva's
shielded in secret everyone's supposed
to say don't let them give away the plot
so when I said that everyone ID not
everyone the lot of people were like oh
my god you still got to see it follows
please go see it it's so good like it's
a 95 percent on Rotten Tomatoes all
sorts of people are really enjoying it
so okay so we uh we went wednesday
because we knew by thursday we'll
probably kicked out theaters because
there's always like there's like one
showtime every day for this movie so
we're like okay this has got to be on
his last legs uh so yeah so we finally
went and saw this movie actually Malcolm
went with us to see it for a second time
because he said he really wanted to take
it in and understand him more some like
oh my god I am so excited to see this
film like everyone's going nuts about it
yeah um I don't know what I thought of
this movie uh all I can really talk
about is sort of the feeling it left on
me I'll talk a little bit about the
story here um pretty much it's it takes
place in the 40s through the future and
what I mean by that is that it doesn't
give you an exact time period I don't
mean like whatever they pick a time
period and they just don't tell you what
it is I mean like there's TVs from the
50s up until like the 80s the shows
they're watching seem mostly 40s some of
the fashions seem very 70s
there's Polaroids but then there's like
a compact that's also like a computer
that this one girl is using that clearly
is something that doesn't exist yet that
is from the future so it's obviously
purposefully trying to be in no specific
time period or like all time periods
um so interesting uh
and pretty much this girl comes across
this boy they're going out and he passes
something
along to her we're some sort of entity
follows whoever has this thing and again
I am NOT I'm trying to say only what's
in the trailer for this uh and they
clearly show that they show that a boy
passes something on to a girl and this
thing can change its identity can look
like anybody and it sort of does it at
random a can go like a little kid it can
look like a tall man uh so he passes it
on to her and he says that if you die it
comes back to me so don't die which is
always nice uh and the whole movie it's
pretty much this thing chasing her down
like a traditional horror film and I'm
trying to figure out how to get rid of
it uh so yeah that's the initial setup I
will say it I'll go into what I think of
a film before I give away like what it
is because like I said everyone so
saying don't don't say what is I I don't
think it's a big deal really of effect
honestly after the guy told me I was
kinda like oh well they say that pretty
early on uh so everyone's acting like
it's the next cabin in the woods like
it's this great satire or something like
that I didn't quite see it as that but I
kind of know where they're coming from
with it but this thing that's passed on
uh you know obviously it's kind of a
slasher film and that this entity
follows these people that that have it
you know that this thing being passed
out it follows and doesn't run always
walks which I like um you would think
like well this thing's not very
efficient and stuff but it's it's
clearly just for the creep factor and it
works and they get some nice scary
people uh to follow these people around
and which is nice I thought that was
really missing from unfriend is that
they had great build up but no scary
payoff as much at least scary imagery I
should say and this has some scary
imagery which I very much enjoy that
gets really creepy people and put dark
stuff under the eyes and just some
creepy creepy creation so I really like
that um but here's the thing about the
film is that it's done in kind of an
abstract way like I said it doesn't pick
a time period it's keeping it very open
and which I'm fine with
I was curious where this was going I was
actually trying to sort of guess uh
guess the twist or the surprise or
whatever the setup was and they have
this emphasis on certain numbers as well
like the and maybe it's coincidence but
some of these were a little too specific
like the house that they start off on is
numbered 1492 okay it could be a
coincidence whatever but then what goes
to another house where the main
character lives uh the three middle
numbers are there the other two numbers
are taken off why would they do that
that's so specific um and there's all
sorts of weird little symbols like that
throughout the film that make me think
okay well this is building up to
something and then the film obviously
purposefully ends abruptly it does not
end unlike a big climax or I hope that
wasn't supposed to be the big climax in
the in this film uh and then you sir
realize all was supposed to be open to
interpretation um here's my problem with
that anyone who knows me knows I love I
love abstract films I love films are
trying something different and in many
respects this one does uh you know I
love David Lynch films I love tree of
life I love Kubrick films you know this
is stuff I really like uh here's my
problem with it though in my opinion uh
this film gave too many rules for it to
live in an abstract world uh films that
really know how to do this know how much
reality to give and how much of an
abstract illusion to give or just a
world based on feelings and ideas you
know Tree of Life is very much an
experience of like maybe when you're
half awake and half asleep or maybe
before you die just suddenly seeing your
life or life in general uh something
like I'm not trying to get something
like a David Lynch film is very much
when you're get what you're half awake
F asleep it's something like where the
wild things are is a world clearly
fueled only by the boy's emotions the
emotions dictate the logic here if they
wanted to go for the abstract and not
have a time period in this can take
place anywhere and stuff that's fine but
there's far too much explanation of the
rules and how this killer works and how
it moves which even then they don't
always stick to there's a lot explaining
about you know this thing when I pass it
on to you
uh it's only in you and you have to pass
on to someone else but then that person
can't die because then it'll come back
to you and they'll keep going down the
line so you can't die now this thing can
only seem be seen by you and the person
you pass it on to and the person that
had it before but nobody else can see it
but it can still pick things up and
people if you throw a blanket on it you
can physically see it and but it can
change shape even though you never see
it changing there are so many rules to
this that it takes you out of the
abstract nature and really this film
does not transport you to like a
different being or a different reality
because you're constantly reminded this
is a slasher film uh you know it's a
horror film and really no more is that
emphasized than in how they pass it on
which I'll get to in a bit I'll say like
spoilers you know don't watch past this
point um but because of that I
personally could not get into whatever
the film was trying to do there's lots
of films I see where if you were to ask
me what was the point of that film uh I
don't know if I could tell you you know
a lot PT Anderson films like Magnolia
punch-drunk love and stuff you know I
can't entirely tell you what the purpose
of the film is but I can tell you that
it the characters were so interesting in
the way it was told was so interesting
and the environment and the reality it
created was so fascinating that I just
want to be along with the ride and I
follow more of the emotions of it then I
did the logic and I think that was the
intent with this the characters are
pretty stock horror film characters even
sort of the set up is a very stock
horror film set up and it has kind of
this interesting angle that is a bit
cabin in the woods ish I suppose um but
anyone saying like this is another camp
in the woods don't believe them that's
not this is not a cabin in the woods
it's not a comedy it's not there's a bit
of a satirical element to it if there's
more I didn't see it the legacy like it
today on a moment um so it was hard for
me to get into this film because I am
constantly distracted not only by how
inconsistent it is but how inconsistent
the tone and the environment was uh
because we're some films as questions in
terms of well this is a question to ask
like you know well what did they say at
the end of loss in translation or what
was in the suitcase in Pulp Fiction you
know these are questions to ask where
you fill in the blanks this one doesn't
work that way see in those you know
they're on purpose we're in this one
they're distractions because you're
asking we'll wait if you shot the the
thing in the neck and it went down and
it got right back up well then you know
you can't kill it yet there's a scene at
the end where they're going to try and
throw a bunch of stuff into a pool to
try to electrocute it but but you know
we can't die that way but then later
there's a scene where they do pretty
much the same thing trying to shoot with
a gun and they're giving the illusion
like it really is dead ever like well
wait it got right back up before why
would it not do it before there's all
these inconsistencies uh that they don't
feel like they're set up to be like this
the answers are not filled by yourself
they're not they're not answered by
yourself they seem very much like we
just sort of forgot to answer this
ourselves um and that's what it seems
like to me that's what it feels like to
me and there's a lot of scenes are set
up that don't go anywhere
uh there's a scene where she's looking
out at a boat and there's uh there's
three boys out there and they're they're
like fishing or something like that and
she's thinking about passing this thing
on you see her start to get address you
know like she's getting her bathing suit
she starts to walk out there and then
you never know what happens which is
like okay so movies are like that you
know you never know but you know she
then pass it on because the thing keeps
coming back to her so you're kinda like
what was the play that scene there's
another scene where the camera is
circling this school and at first I was
really in love with this shot uh they
walk in they're gonna find out some
information on this other kid and you
see this girl far away in a white jacket
is walking kind of like how this thing
walks and it circles around you see them
getting information and it comes around
you see her a little closer maybe you
didn't even know us her early on the
shop and AC she's a little closer
circles around again you see she's a
little closer and they see they find the
information and they walk out and then
you see him in the car there's that girl
again in the background and she's
walking getting closer it's like oh and
then they focus on the girls like oh
here we go
cut you you never see where that goes so
maybe the idea again is creating this
environment like hey you just sort of
never know and there are times where
they play with it like you don't know if
the person walking is this thing or if
it's just a person but it's done in such
a way where you kind of go well that was
just a cheat that never follow through
or a seam did not really have a purpose
um and it the the scenes like that the
questions in this movie did not pull me
in they pushed me away and I found it
really distracting with that said
there's still some good stuff in here
there's good the creepy environment is
very good I like the people they choose
for for this thing to infect uh or at
least you know have them walk you know
that the people they choose to just walk
slowly and creepily really walk slow and
creepily very well I know it sounds
silly but it's like they do it really
well uh and when they're building up
like what's what's this person gonna see
what's gonna be behind the corner and
stuff like that majority of the time
they do not do a fake-out jump scare
they show something scary there which
I'm like it's gotten to a point now
where every time they're building
something's gonna scare you and then
there's nothing there and then the scare
is right behind them it's been done so
many times it's not shot
King anymore so now the new shock is
build up that something's going to be
there and actually have something be
there you know it's like Marvel idea you
know but it's like we've just done the
fake out so much it's not a fake out we
can all see you coming so just building
up saying something is going to be there
and then something is there actually is
much scarier uh and I'm glad this week
picked up on that now there's one or two
jump scares not many uh and they're
pretty silly and everyone jumps but it's
like oh it's a ball oh the wall falls
down as you're a person stupid um but
again I understand you keeping the
tension up and you had to feel a little
uncomfortable so I kinda get that you
want to keep the you know sort of like
sit the tension up so um yeah but my
biggest problem before I get to what
this thing is is that I felt that the
world and the environment they were
trying to create uh was not was not
involving enough um in that it did not
create enough of an abstract world or an
idea behind it that I could pick up on
without constantly being pulled back
into this is a horror film you know
we're in a slasher film I'm not like oh
my god I really feel like I'm this
person I really understand this person
psychology or stuff like that it's like
there's not their stock horror film
characters which is fine but you're
gonna try and do something that's like
different and innovative and artsy and
hope interpretation what did it mean you
have to have something more interesting
you have to have something that's going
to suck in much more than this idea uh
and because the characters actions at
the time don't make sense the guy that
does this to her um you know he straps
her to a wheelchair to show her this
thing and any drugs are they drops her
off at her house you know tied up and
stuff like that her friends see her and
go and pick her up and stuff they
finally find this guy and they want to
find out what this is so they locate his
house and his parents are there his
mother is anyway and they just sit down
talk with him okay if I was this chick I
would be so fucking pissed off of this
guy like you know okay you give me some
God
answer you tell me what's going on I'm
gonna call the fucking cops on you you
know I can report your ass for you you
drugged me you tied me up you helped me
against my will
and you have this thing chase us down do
you try me there are a million like you
know legitimate crimes he can charge
against this guy they just sit down and
talk and he's like oh no I'm
uncomfortable talking about it I it's
like why didn't nobody act accordingly
in this film uh Elling so when they're
trying to kill this thing everyone in
the theater I can hear them talking you
know this is a scene where uh they're
gonna throw stuff in the pool a bunch of
electricity to try and shock it
everyone's like wait Quinn the thing
following them start to throw the stuff
cuz they have the girl in the pool Coon
he throws stuff in the pool that's what
he does wait don't they remember that
when they tried to kill it before it
didn't die so probably won't work this
time
that's what happens I mean it's bizarre
how much this stuff doesn't add up
and even when you see how this thing
kills uh it kills off this boy in the
middle of the film I don't think maybe
the way to who it is or anything there's
a lot of boys and girls uh but you see
how it kills and then you go back to the
opening when you saw a girl die from
this thing against is the intro you see
a girl die from this thing and they
don't add up they don't match up the
same ways that they die so nothing in
this film seems consistent but it does
not feel like the inconsistencies were
intentional um with that said I'm not by
any means saying I'm right on this I'm
not saying that if you like this you're
a moron or you're reading into something
that's not there I'm not saying that at
all I'm saying very much that a I
couldn't emotionally get sucked into the
abstract of and the abstract element of
it and B I didn't see what the intention
was outside of this sort of clever twist
I'm a twist ish on this idea of horror
films um that just seems like almost
like any other or horror film except
that they do it in a more artsy way if I
have to hear that fucking music start to
build and then just cut stop I mean it's
like the first couple times I was good
it created
double feeling but then by the 10th or
11th I'm done I like when it's giving
louder louder - and I'm like Gaea
whatever it's gonna just cut in the
middle I'll be going - and that's
supposed to make us uncomfortable and it
does it again it does it so many times
that it just slapped me out of whatever
world or environment it was trying to
create so okay so that's the basic
review I'll go into what this thing
finally is so if you don't want to hear
you don't want it ruined uh you know
turn it off go see it for yourself I
like sad not saying I'm right or you had
to feel the exact same way by no means
because this film is getting a lot of
critical praise uh and I would very much
like to know if other people have the
same reaction or if it's like no no dunk
you clearly miss this very obvious thing
like it could be so so there's that so
if you don't want to know what this
thing how this thing is transmitted
go ahead stop it now so you're still
here you want to know it's transmitted
it's pretty much an evil STD every time
somebody sleeps with someone this
monster comes and tries to get them it's
a very clever setup because obviously
this is where people say it's like cabin
in the woods it's why do people who have
sex in horror films always die now of
course you could say the ethical the
moral and stuff and that they're trying
to get this message across
but here it's very much the monster only
goes after people who have had who have
this this disease or whatever this STD
and pass it on to someone else so that's
a very clever setup and I guess I can
see where they connected to camp in the
woods because it's why do these genres
yeah why does this happen in the genre
and they're trying to sort of explain it
and give this angle up a like so out of
sight of that there's little to no
comedy in this at all so so do not
figure gain cabin in the woods uh so
with that said I like this set up it's
not a bad setup um but I didn't and you
have a great setup for for satire and
commentary but I don't understand
why they took they just want a
traditional horror film with the story
but went this really weird abstract take
with the style that the two did not seem
to go together and that's not at all to
say it can't I thought it went well with
the shining if you ask me what the
intention of the shining was I wouldn't
be able to tell you but like from the
first frame you're clearly not in
reality no Kubrick film are you ever in
reality you're in this very different
like state of being and
uncomfortableness and coldness uh you
know the way they talk the way the
camera moves everything about it is sort
of in this weird state of being so it
can be done um but with this like I said
if if in the shining they were
constantly saying well now here's the
limitations of the boys power and now
now you can only think it between this
time because then it gets cut off but
then if you contact me you know past
that time that's when my ability gets
cut off oh by the way the ghost is
actually the ghost of this other guy who
can only come around only when the Sun
is uh not only when the moon is a full
moon and only when this is gone
if there's too many rules it ceased to
create that environment anymore and you
become more aware it's a movie that's a
horror film because uh you know gremlins
clearly there's rules to these things
and they don't even make that much sense
but that's sort of the goofy nature of
the film
now Kremlin's is not trying to be
abstract it's a straightforward kind of
B film and that's great and works
wonderfully but when you're trying to
explain no no when you give it to me
only only we can see it and now you can
see it but physically all the other
people can't see it but they can touch
it and it can interact but they have to
guess where it is kinda like the
Invisible Man but then when you shoot it
in the neck you'll go down but come back
up and we shoe in the head oh go down
for an even longer amount of time and it
just gets so stock it becomes such a
stock horror film with an interesting
style for a while but then it just kind
of gets old and I remember kind of
looking at my watch at the end you know
my father who has a watch anymore but
bow again my phone saying so how long is
this movie again and when is it gonna
you know it give me the payoff that I'm
waiting for and the payoff never comes
in the payoff is you know fill in your
own your own explanation which I usually
love I usually love that kind of stuff
but did not create an environment where
that was inviting it create an
environment where I doubted I did not
trust the filmmaker to ask me
intelligent questions if that made sense
uh where with someone like a David Lynch
or so forth like I do because I'm like
what are you trying to say it's
something different it's something
intriguing and it has brought me to this
new world in this new way of sort of
thinking about film and experience
things is brought me to a new experience
this didn't feel like an experience to
me this felt like a horror film with an
artsy style that didn't always connect
to the film there's a scene where one of
the things that takes the shape of is
this is this woman who's peeing her
pants now it's a scary looking woman and
they build it up very nicely
why is she peeing her pants well you'll
have to draw your own conclusion no
because you're still keeping me in the
traditional horror film setup that these
are five or six stock characters are
gonna get you know axed off slowly um
and even some things like one girl is
really likes to sleep a lot and likes to
eat a lot uh I thought are they each
supposed to be like a deadly sin or
something like even when I'm trying to
read into this even with like the 1492
I'm like is it that we brought STDs to
America when Columbus died like and I
realize I'm reading much more deeper
into this than either what was intended
or or or beyond what I wanted to care
about so so that's my initial reaction
to the film I'm not saying I totally
hated it uh I I don't even know if I if
I even kind of disliked it it was just
that it did not whatever it was trying
to do I did not catch on to and I don't
know if that a fault
with the film or with me as as an
audience member because there could be
lots of audience members are like boom
I get it I got what this film was trying
to do you know I mean someone could
watch it be like it's symbolic of the
Holocaust and everybody gets it except
me uh so I'm not saying at all that like
if you don't like it you know it's not
good it's not like district night where
I clearly know what it's saying it's
just so poorly done in my opinion I get
a lot of people like if you like it
great I thought was awful um by the way
how are other films doing what Chafee
and uh Matt Damon's terminators I hear
they're really good I'm being a dick
sorry
sure aliens gonna be great I really
don't like that guy stuff I'm sorry I'm
sorry
uh but it nevertheless if you do great
but the symbolism in those films is very
obvious here it it might be too abstract
at least for me uh it was hard for me to
figure out what it was trying to do what
kind of tone it was trying to get and
what it was trying to accomplish outside
of just STDs or bad use protection
um you know and that there is sort of
this hey is that kind of funny how this
always happens in horror films element
uh you know now here's a little bit of a
reason at least with this thing so yeah
I this is one of the films I actually
would really love if people comment
below and say if you liked it and you're
one of the 95% of rotten tomatoes that
just absolutely loves it and see says
this genius work tell me why because I'm
really really curious I'm curious if I'm
missing something and I'm very open to
acknowledging that if I miss something I
miss something uh but yeah go ahead and
sort of sure sort of share with me what
you got out of it and why you thought it
was good if you hate it you're like you
know Doug you're right this is a piece
of shit and everything that that fine I
would kindly ask don't comment
necessarily on that if you wanna give
like an analysis of
found that's fine but like don't don't
say like you know don't listen these
idiots is stupid and sizes I don't do
that you know I'm here for ideas I'm
here to listen and I'm here to find out
if there's something I'm missing and if
everyone's like no no y'all miss
anything is just you know emotionally
hit me and I thought was clattering fair
enough really just didn't do it for me
uh or if there's something like really
obvious I'm just not catching on to uh
you know I've been known to miss stuff
like it we all miss stuff I love to know
so go ahead sir put down different
thoughts or interpretations or why you
enjoyed it if you did enjoy the film
because I really would like to sort of
compare and contrast cuz all the reviews
I've read were very like so many of them
were built up on you know I don't want
to give it away which I don't get it is
it really that big a deal is it really
that big a thing ah so um you know cabin
the woods I get but I don't get why keep
the secret shy I don't understand uh but
that that's the key word I don't
understand uh it's not that I'm right
room and you're wrong it's more that I
don't understand see if you can explain
it to me uh so yeah that's about it uh
as of now I actually like unfriended
better which I didn't think would happen
um I just thought was more creative and
the pacing was better and I was more
interested in the characters were were
more fun and interesting even though
they were kind of stock characters too
uh but they were just more interesting
than these characters so yeah like I
said that doesn't mean it can't change
or someone can point out something that
I clearly missed maybe but yeah go ahead
sir leave in the comments talk about
your thoughts about the film if you
enjoyed it and what you enjoyed about it
and yeah let's see we can figure out
let's just see if we can figure it
follows out so uh that's about it and I
will see you guys later and hey if
you're gonna be at c2e2 this weekend go
ahead check me out I got a booth I've
promoted the hell out of it so if just
another friendly reminder uh so yeah
that's about it and I will see you guys
later
take care